coincidence or a chilling attempt to
silence Republicans demanding answers
after the IRS showed up to the house of
a Twitter files journalist this happened
on the same day that Matt taibi was
testifying about how the government
tries to censor free speech
effectively news media became an arm of
a state-sponsored thought policing
system this is a grave threat to people
of all political Persuasions I do find
it scary I I think it's none of the
government's business what which
journalists a private company talks to
and why it's usually a canary in the
coal mine that something worse is coming
in terms of an effort to exercise
control over the press and so on that
level it's it's absolutely disturbing
is not commenting on the issue but says
he wanted the committee to be aware of
the situation now fellow Twitter files
journalist Michael schellenberger says
he's extremely concerned with the
message the agency may have been trying
to send
extremely concerning I mean maybe it's a
coincidence that the IRS happened to
visit Matt taibi on the day that he was
testifying on the weaponization of the
federal government against American
citizens or maybe somebody was trying to
send a message if it's the latter or
this obviously is deeply inappropriate
and maybe illegal and so I'm very glad
to see that
Congressman Jordan is going to be
looking into this obviously there's got
to be some paper trail on this we need
to see what's going on because it's
extremely troubling if indeed we've seen
the IRS being weaponized against Matt
taibi okay so to that point Jim Jordan
by the way has sent this letter to the
head of the IRS and also the treasury
secretary says the circumstances
surrounding the unannounced and
unprompted visited to Mr taibi's home at
the exact time he was testified to
Congress about the most serious
government abuse he has witnessed well
it's incredible judge that's the word he
used it it is incredible and you know
the irony continues when today Garland
was before the committee testifying
about his role in targeting uh the
Department of Justice uh using the
Department of Justice to Target parents
and accusing them of being domestic
terrorists which is another
weaponization of of a federal agency but
you know you think about it when the IRS
comes after you you get a letter your
accountant gets a letter since when do
IRS agents show up at your door and
since when do they show up at your door
when you're about to testify and the
biggest thing that's going on in America
having to do with the with the
coordination between the feds the FBI
and possible election interferences
related to the 2020 presidential
election but you know this is something
that the Democrats have been doing
historically during the Obama
Administration Lois Lerner who was
accused of targeting those conservatives
who had 501 1c3's of course she goes and
testifies and then she reads the
statement then then claims the Fifth
Amendment saying I don't have to testify
anyway the Fifth Amendment the Congress
then moved for her to be prosecuted and
of course the Obama justice department
says oh we're not going to prosecute her
uh for contempt this is digital
McCarthyism this is intimidation of a
kind that we haven't seen since the
McCarthy days you do not and you want to
know what what Biden's going to do with
87 000 new IRS agents that's exactly
what they're going to do they're going
to Target their political enemies and
they're going to go to their houses so
much for this oh we're only going after
billionaires that's nonsense well
Jessica what do you make of that I mean
the judge lines out you know a lot of
past practice that has led people to
currently have a healthy dose of
skepticism about the IRS and other
federal agencies as well totally I I
think digital McCarthyism may be a
stretch here but it
it seems bad I mean maybe it is a
coincidence it seems incredibly unlikely
that it's that day when they even say
then call me back four days later you
would imagine that we have to know to
say call me back right away or call me
back tomorrow and here's why it's about
X Y and Z issues
um it doesn't seem good I think it
deserves an explanation because these
are the kinds of things that get in
people's heads and it creates a
permanent impression of it even if it's
not taken as a political move of any way
just the general distrust of our
institutions where people say you know
they turn around and say like I just
want to do my taxes on a postcard and I
don't think we need to have the IRS at
all
um I think they need to answer for it
the idea though
that Matt haibi you know like blew the
roof off the idea that the government is
controlling our social media things all
we basically found out from that was
that Donald Trump has thin skin which we
knew and wanted Chrissy Teigen thrown
off and with the various things some of
this Twitter stuff we saw regular
meetings between the FBI and
conversations with dni and others inside
of Twitter so Jesse even if this is
totally coincidental did nobody check
like their you know Palm Pilots or
whatever like hey that day is not the
day you should show up at that time
anyway on the hill that day they sent an
IRS agent to a journalist's house
think about that imagine Trump sending
an IRS agent to some liberal journalist
house the day the journalist was
testifying on Capitol Hill about his
corruption exactly this would be a
constitutional crisis you'd have
hearings you'd had investigations and
this IRS commissioner is dirty first of
all he went to Duke so you know yuck and
he was the guy that they brought in to
clean up the irst party targeting he was
the one that Biden and Obama brought in
to say you know what we didn't find any
intentional misconduct oh yeah and we
were targeting liberal groups too yeah
goodbye and then he went to a nice
Boston consulting firm oh and then Joe
Biden happened to bring him back as as
commissioner so the funny thing is
Hunter Biden doesn't pay taxes he didn't
pay 2 million dollars in taxes IRS never
visited him IRS visited the journalist
who exposed the cover-up of Hunter Biden
that's insane this is the same guy that
wants to Target waitresses tips
your 600 venmo transactions this is not
good and this guy this dirty Commish
from duke needs to come out and testify
under oath will he though I mean Jim
Jordan has given them Greg until April
10th to turn over all the documents
about who decided about this visit and
what was going on you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna go out on a limb right here and
say that the IRS is a corrupt sham it's
a machine of theft they take your money
by force you know that if you don't pay
you're going to jail they should be
investigated they should be arrested the
very worst of them should be put away
for life and I'm saying this it's purely
as a coincidence that you know tax days
in three weeks so uh if they come for me
you know why it's because what I just
said now look I don't even care if this
is a coincidence this is Banana Republic
third world crap this is government
intimidation I mean thankfully they
didn't level his house or poison his dog
and claim it had rabies because that's
what they do in other countries and this
is just a taste and I feel actually I
feel bad for taibi and this is crazy for
someone like me who 15 years ago would
make fun of him relentlessly remember
when he was in the boat with Sean Penn
during Hurricane Katrina but yet taibi
and Glenn Greenwald these people have
been consistent and I haven't been and I
think heeda he and Greenwald deserve
apologies from people like me and people
on the right who thought who thought
they were just your typical Lily liver
level Lily liver liberals when in fact
they were they kept to their principles
even as their allies desert them now and
in fact they are the true journalists
and you got to wonder where the other
journalists are who were their peers at
Rolling Stone and elsewhere what
happened to them I mean those are the
imposters you're apologizing now I
always apologize he's making things
right do I get an apology you know what
you've been disrespectful
liberals very good and Greg has a very
nuanced position on the IRS yes I do hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now